[Music]
okay okay okay where's up guys I'm tphd
here and welcome back to some extended
coverage of the world's most densely
packed keynote WWDC 2019 so one of the
many things they showed off on stage
during that two-hour plus event was the
next version of iOS iOS 13 so I sat
through that two-and-a-half hour keynote
so you don't have to and I installed the
super buggy iOS 13 beta on my iPhone so
you don't have to either so these are
the best of those new features coming to
iOS for your future iPhone or maybe your
current iPhone top 5 iOS 13 features so
number 5 is the speed optimizations so
this is a pretty minor thing it seems
they sort of opened with it for a hot
minute and if you blink you might have
missed it but they made some pretty bold
claims about iOS 13 speed versus the
already really fast I was 12 they went
along the lines of 30% faster face idea
unlocking and 50% smaller packages for
app downloads and 60% smaller for app
updates so there should be much faster
downloads and installing of apps
especially the bigger ones and two times
faster launch speeds Wow now again this
is a beta so these things are still
being worked on and I don't know if it's
a placebo but the one thing I do feel
like I notice is the faster face ID
unlock especially when putting it side
by side against iOS 12 the two times
faster app launching speeds that is
tough to see because the beta is so
buggy and things are constantly crashing
and lagging all the time so I can't
verify that but I'm really looking
forward to that overall iowa's 12 is
already faster than previous versions
especially on older devices so I'll
welcome another free speed upgrade and
number four is shared wireless audio so
this is like a headphone splitter but
for air pods so they showed it on stage
as two people sort of holding your
iPhones near each other and then
enabling audio sharing so they can
basically hear the same thing from one
source so then that gets our mind going
about different ways that this could be
useful
that could be fun for two people next to
each other on a plane watching the same
movie together but both with wireless
headphones or maybe going for a run with
someone and both listening to the same
music at the same time things like that
so it seems like a pretty cool feature
to have now I say seems like it because
I haven't gotten it to work yet on my
beta I tried for a while apparently
other people have gotten it to work I'm
just gonna attribute it to the fact that
it's super unstable but this is
something that I'm gonna be thankful for
having when traveling so it's a solid
new audio feature that of course takes
advantage of having bluetooth 5.0 and
number three is the new keyboard and I
can put new and air quotes because
androids had this feature for I want to
say maybe about a decade now but the
stock keyboard now and iOS 13 has swipe
typing and that's it so you could do
this with third-party keyboards like
swipe or the Google keyboard if you
install them on your iPhone in the past
but now it'll be built-in so you can
have all your keyboard suggestions and
everything you're used to in one place
with swipe typing I personally love it
for typing longer sentences on bigger
screens not sure if this is also coming
to iPad OS but it's welcome on the
iPhone ok so those last we were a bit
more minor updates as you could tell but
I think these next to the top two are
pretty major so number two is an
overhaul of what's maybe one of the top
3 most used apps on anyone's iPhone the
Photos app so I got a pretty good demo
of this at WWDC but it's also working
pretty well on my beta 2 basically the
UI is organized a bit different and it
gets a bunch of new features that I like
so at the bottom you have these couple
of different photo modes you have all
photos mode which is literally just a
grid of everything then days mode which
lets you scroll through the best photos
you've taken each day with sort of smart
highlights of certain ones that thinks
you'll like then months again zooms a
bit out and gives you the best photos of
each month and then years again zooms
out giving you a throwback of some of
the best stuff from each previous year
2018 2017 2016 etc sort of a rewind of
what happened around that day each year
and then when you're actually in a photo
the editing controls are pretty sweet
they got an upgrade they're much more
extensive and smartly laid out and fluid
you can do auto adjustments if you want
or really dig down into there with
contrast and color sharpening noise
reduction and there's also red eye
correction built in and you can still
mess with the same filters as before but
the best part to me anyway is that this
also applies to videos so you can mess
with the same edits to color contrast
sharpness even noise reduction for video
is still there which is amazing
and this also means you can now rotate a
video which you literally could not do
in iOS 12 Photos app along with flipping
and there's tilting and warping and
perspective changes for every single
clip you can even change the aspect
ratio so there's a lot going on now I'm
a fan and I hope Google photos also can
build this stuff into eventually and
that brings us to number one the most
anticipated feature of iOS it got the
loudest cheer or at least one super loud
one from the crowd and that is dark mode
in iOS 13 so lover 2 hated people have
been wishing for this and asking for a
few years
the default all-white colors of iOS can
be blinding so now there's a system-wide
dark mode you can enable it from the
control center and it turns all your
stock apps and menus and notifications
and widgets and everything dark dark
backgrounds light text the whole stock
UI now all the third-party apps inside
those you still have to change them
yourself so if you want everything dark
like YouTube and Twitter and all the
rest you have to toggle those yourself
but yeah that quick toggle for the UI is
now super simple and easy to switch
everything black and now with that
there's also some new wallpapers to go
with it built into iOS 13 so these
actually the couple new ones with a
little dark and light logo in the corner
are dark mode compatible I guess I'll
say so they will automatically switch
when you toggle dark mode they'll switch
between them back and forth between dark
and light plus if you don't use one of
these you can turn on dimming
so whatever wallpaper you have will dim
to be darker if you have dark mode on
and hey you might even save a little bit
of battery since the iPhones of course
all use OLED displays that don't use
power when the color black is displayed
so there it is finally dark mode for iOS
13 there's also a couple smaller things
that didn't quite make this list kind of
like how every year Apple always has
that little extra slide with all the
stuff that they wanted to make sure you
knew we're getting included but they
didn't have time to go over so if you
actually pause on that exact slide from
the keynote this year they actually did
it again and there's something called
Wi-Fi selection in control center so now
if you're in control center you can 3d
touch the Wi-Fi icon and a list of
networks pop up seems like the intuitive
thing to do
bluetooth does the same thing and that's
actually something that the newest beta
of
Android just got rid of oh there's also
a emoji improvements so you can add
piercings now to your momochi or even
put air pods in its ears so I guess
that's a thing worth knowing
there's also login with Apple which is
designed to replace other social logins
but with much more security instead as
the focus like a really impressive
dedication to shielding your information
from the companies that keep asking for
your login so they'll generate a
dedicated login email address randomly
every time you log in so they can't
swipe yours very nice and then the
volume box of course is finally fixed so
for reference here was iOS 12 and the
ridiculous volume changing and here is
iOS 13 right next to the volume rocker
nice and small clean much better so that
is it that is the best of the new
features coming to iOS 13 that we know
about anyway my personal favorite is
still dark modes so obviously I put that
at number one but let me know what
you're looking forward to most in the
comments below and this is still super
early in the beta it'll be a public beta
in about a month and then eventually
rolling out to people beyond that so you
can expect it stable in a little waste
time but either way that's been it thank
you for watching catch you guys later
peace